[Music]
today I'm gonna tell you about some of
our work on machine learning the first
reference right and specifically in
service of like future engineering and
being able to write your business logic
into your future in one place have it
run everywhere and also illuminate some
kind of common causes of errors class of
errors that can come up and like kind of
destroy your model performance so first
I'll tell you a little bit about she's
running out straight like what we do and
what some of our machine learning
problems are about like what are some of
these Forney folds and developing
features that we run into and our
approach to solving them and then just
kind of like what's actually running
introductions so if you're not familiar
with strength strength is a toolkit for
starting and running an internet
business if you want to have a business
especially an online business you
usually need to like have a way for
people to pay you like make money and so
a big part of what we do is provide
infrastructure or FEMA's like billions
of dollars a year with probably lots of
the businesses that you do that work at
so because our users are businesses and
they're kind of online businesses it
always sending us transactional via that
we're going they're growing machine
learning is like a pretty good tool to
kind of help us make decisions at scale
whether it's in our charge flow or about
our accounts one of the things that's
kind of unique about us is that our
machine learning is also kind of like hi
days like it's not that which it won't
look great or like you know baby you get
shown the wrong ad it's like we could
like shut down you know a really big
user by mistake if we're wrong and our
machine learning or like a lot of bad
transactions through and that could hit
bottom line of every deserves so it's
really important that will be
reproducible and what we think will
happen from training a model is actually
what happens in production especially if
you think about something like
potentially letting Agilent payments
early might not find out about that for
a while so here are a few examples where
we use machine learning those in our
user kissing product as well to
contrarily radar as our fraud product
this page is actually as in today out of
d and we did a big news release but
we'll use some of the stuff i'll talk
about but basically for every
transaction in real time we evaluate
whether or not we think the payment is
good or bad and will like block it or
give users tools to decide what to do if
we think it might not be good this is
kind of an example of like what it looks
like if we block the payment a sponge
illan and here you're already starting
to see like here's the feature right
because we try until the user why did we
block with image it will kind of talk
about like where these features come
from we won't talk about it kind of like
a separate talk or how do we choose what
to show here but if you're interested in
not asking at office hours another place
we use machine learning is in our
billion subscriptions product like have
a subscription every month that you're
in charging someone is a business one of
the charges fails you wanted to be able
to retry so we use machine learning to
figure out like what is the optimal time
to retry in the back side of the revenue
and then we also use machine learning a
lot like internally as well to optimize
our operations so you gotta let seven
years
kind of like hope suggests resolution
pounds for someone's tumor support
customer support request we have like
kind of a Titans of agent Phil being
trained and like using the models kind
of like interacting with them we also do
a lot of learning for understanding like
where users are and whether there's
something like whether there's bad
actors when suddenly they're not
supposed to or something like that so
across all these applications these are
pretty much all pieces where you're
trying to do prediction of
classification and you may want some set
of features to help you do that and then
so a lot of these applications are also
kind of like very old time driven
particularly our fraud product darling
you know in the time it takes to have
your online credit card accepted we not
only need to do the full trotted
allegation we also need to do things
like send it to our networks and there's
not actually let a lot of time to get
all that computation that will factor in
a little bit so when I walk it out okay
so now you know kind of told you like
why what are the allegations is where
are we using modeling but like how do we
build a model right so if you take you
know of Coursera injuries class y
machine learning or something they'll
probably give me something like this
right so each each row is some event and
you have a bunch of features they have
some value and then have some some
beautiful label that has kind of like
just like know what the ground truth is
so this is kind of like the fiction
about machine learning that like someone
just like the stove on you this
beautiful matrix of data that all you
need to do this training model on it
it'll it'll look the same in training in
production and like it'll just be like
really easy to create this right but I
think a lot of times you know that's
already come up here yesterday and today
like kind of creating the features and
like being able to get to this point is
actually the hard part like this part
where you take this matrix and you like
have a function that uses a model that's
not always so hard like whether it's
doesn't matter if it's like a deep
learning model early
gradients to decision trees or linear
model that's often like not actually
kind of the hard part of your production
machine learning so I'm not going to
talk about that at all and just to kind
of like give you an example here for the
case of radar where we're trying to
classify transactions as good or bad if
you had like a decision tree model right
this is sort of like a visualization of
what it would look like so you'd like to
have this like nice tall skinny matrix
that you can like compute all your
features from but you know the reality
especially when you're working with
real-time systems is a little bit more
like this there's some data being shoved
at you from it a bunch of different
places like maybe you have some
databases maybe you have some coffee
queues maybe you reach out to some
external services like you want to do
geo IP lookups or you you know want to
somehow like enrich your internal data
with something outside of your
organization and it's just kind of like
all shoved at you and then you have to
figure out what to do to kind of like
put it into this like normal seeing
matrix so then you can use to train your
algorithm and again kind of like here's
an example to sort of think through like
what are the features from the case of
our fraud product radar so there's kind
of three columns here the amount of the
charge the country associated with the
credit card the number of countries that
card was used from say in the past day
so like you know if my credit card was
used yesterday in Africa and in Europe
and in South America like that's
probably a pretty good indication that
the next transaction is fraudulent so
then you can kind of think about like
where do these features come from like
amount in u.s. to you that's probably
something you can just like kind of pull
directly off the charge whether it's an
event or in your database country of the
card like maybe that's in the same place
maybe you saved it somewhere when you
created the card and then it starts
getting really complicated when you
think about this is even just like a
pretty simple case like how many
countries was this card used from in the
past hour like how are you going to
compute that and how are you gonna make
sure it's the same thing in real time in
production on the trading side so
basically like sort of as we looked over
all of these two
machine learning problems like you know
the transaction fraud case understanding
our users like looking at customer
support or the optimal timing for
subscription recharges we noticed that
there were a bunch of problems that they
all had in common and figuring out like
what features to build the model with
and how to calculate them so one is that
like I mentioned you know this data kind
of like comes at you from all these
different directions you have a bunch of
different data stores a bunch of
different event streams like how do you
fit them all together another problem is
that you always you know you always want
to train your model on like the state of
the world at the time when the
prediction would have been made and so
it gets like kind of complicated to
start getting that right when your
features get more complicated like even
for the case where it's how many say how
many distinct card countries was this
car country's was this card used from in
the past day like it's a little bit of
work to start kind of keeping track of
that and if you add another layer too on
top of that it gets like really my
inventing and easy to mess up sort of
similarly to that a pretty common
mistake in future engineering is having
like kind of this label leakage which
I'll give you an example of but
basically where you like use future data
that you didn't have at the time and
sort of build that into your model so
I'll show you another example but like
you know what encase could be if you are
recording some records like when you
make a sale all steel or something and
when you know it's going to close you
just like don't fill in some fields so
then not filling in fields looks like an
awesome predictor of like closing a deal
but actually that's like not meaningful
at all right and you're gonna get some
weird results if that's what your model
predicts so those are all kind of on the
especially those middle two are sort of
like correctness issues I think another
couple issues people often run into that
we saw are like how do you make sure
just that things are the same like your
stack for training your models you may
be writing like a spark job or some
batch job but maybe in production like
your application runs in Ruby so you're
gonna like go rewrite all your features
in Ruby
so like especially for kind of edge
cases how are you gonna make sure that
that code is like actually producing the
same results so basically these are
these are the problems that we were
trying to like aim to solve and
basically like especially focusing on
sort of like eliminating these classes
of errors around time' where joins in
linkage by not letting people make those
mistakes just kind of like taking it out
of possibility and here is kind of like
another example of this problem of label
weak ajar training on feature data like
let's say I'm a future engineer and I'm
like trying to figure out I have like a
great idea that you know probably I
should look at the fraud rate for the
email of the user that seems like
something that might be predictive of
fraud so I'm you know in this case I'm
the example user and I made a couple of
charges on a couple different businesses
and then after the fact like you know I
guess I was using my pile of stolen
credit cards so both of those were
disputed by the actual cardholder so
then you know the problem here would be
if you calculate the fraud rate at the
end of the sequence of events you're
like wow Kelly I am 100 percent fraud
awesome and then if you pull that back
into your model that's going to cause
problems because of the time of the
charges you didn't actually know that
that was the case you didn't have that
data and I'll just point out that like
in this case we're mostly talking about
features for kind of like fancy machine
learning models but rolls are actually
models too so even if you're just
thinking about writing rules you kind of
like me to consider this as well so this
is a picture of from our radar product
where we let people kind of also write
block or allow rules and we try and give
them some statistics about like what
would have happened if they applied this
in the past
so that they don't like accidentally
block all their payments so here it's
also important that you get sort of like
a realistic snapshot of what your
features were at a given point in time
so basically when we kind of like step
back and thought about like how can we
sort of eliminate these types of cases
of things like label leakage or like
messing up a type of way or join and how
can we also kind of provide like a
really rich set of features that users
are able to build without having to
think a lot about the implementation we
kind of came to this model of features
and events there's kind of two core
concepts and everything is sort of
designed around this so basically you
know events are like things that come
out of a Kafka queue they're just like
things that happen at particular times
and then a feature is more of like a
continuously valued thing but the key
thing in this model is that like the
only thing that can change the value of
a feature is an event so it's kind of
like a closed system I guess you are
like a physicist like me maybe you think
about it that way and so basically like
you know all we need to do are sort of
figure out like what operations you can
take on features and events and then
we're gonna make our system kind of take
care of like figuring out how to do the
lookups in time like automatically so
yeah basically the input matrix to your
model is just like a feature that's
attached to an event so for any event
you can do you can sort of like look up
like what was the value of the feature
at the time of an event so if I want to
know like you know I have some charged
event and I want to know how many how
many countries was this card used from
at that time I can just kind of like do
that lookup and then basically this is
kind of all we need to either do like
model training or to do evaluation like
real time serving one thing that's
important for this is that we need all
of these data inputs and like we assume
that they are immutable evented data and
this makes this picture like basically
work
so it's not very important to read all
the code but this kind of like a very
basic sketch of what these two core
types are events and features so you
know for events you have it's actually
more like a stream of events and then
there are individual instances and these
are things that pop out of Kafka and
they're associated with a particular
timestamp and a future
on the other hand a future is like about
a thing so you know it could be what's
the country of this associated with this
credit card is like a feature about a
card or like how old am I is like about
me like it's not about Dan doesn't make
sense so any feature always has the
subject of type K here and then one nice
thing is that that kind of lets us like
partition updates to the future by
different case and so you know K could
be your user it could be like some ID it
could be anything but a future is kind
of like movies about a thing and then we
kind of give our users our machine
learning engineers an API to kind of
like you know define operations so like
for an event you can you can filter an
event like for stripe we have live mode
API we have a testimony API in the test
mode API is just protesting so we like
throw all that data out like every time
we want to train a model about what
happens in the actual world or like we
can have a map like if we only want to
take like some sums we want to kind of
like take some function like take the
first letter of the name coming out
similarly we have kind of operations we
can do on feature so like a future dot
map basically just like takes some some
of the columns and apply some operation
and then you get like a new column so in
the example mentioned here let's say
that we have a business and we have
their total charge count and their total
charge amount we can just like use a map
to write the average amount and so some
of the things you've probably noticed
here
there's nothing about time there's
nothing about implementation all you
have to do
right like business logic of your future
that's kind of the goal and then like
where it gets really cool and
interesting is that you can do you can
kind of like go between features and
events and come up with some pretty
complicated stuff so like an event dot
look up will read a future so you know
when you're generating the training data
you always want the events to see the
value of the feature at the time as it
was like at the time of the event so
basically like we give our machine
learning engineers sort of like a really
nice primitive to do this so the event
is kind of you're just kind of like
sampling the future at different points
in time when you do this look up and
then you can kind of like join these
things together to create some pretty
complex features we also you know
provide something like a future not
latest where you can say like just you
know tell me the latest value the future
as it is now which may or may not be
defined like nothing's happened already
and so like you know our machine
learning engineers can take a bunch of
different events and they can say like
take this feature here and then do this
look up into this other event and
combine it here and map it over there
and they can write like these really
complex features over a large number
events using just this really simple API
where they can't get anything wrong with
respect to thinking about the time and
this is what we call kind of like
temporal consistency the system kind of
manages all of this for you
so these are some kind of like silly
trivial example features that are
actually basically like unit tests in
our code so in this case you know a
someone who really likes dogs was the
creator of this code so we have some
event streams that are like barks by the
dog jumps by the dog howls by the dog
and then it's really easy to do things
like write a feature for has a dog of a
particular name barked or like you know
what's what's the average volume
associated with some dog when you look
at their stream of barks and their
stream of howls so these are kind of
silly examples but you know if you think
back to kind of some of our other
examples like if you're trying to
identify like a bad actor in our system
some of the more complicated types of
things we could do are like you know we
could look at features like what's the
fraud rate for that users email domain
or like a rating across all of their
transactions looking at the distinct
email domain names what's the average
fraud rate across all of those for the
user and those things would be like
really hard to define if you had to
actually kind of go write the future
code and the time and figure out like
what were these things at the time of
the transaction but they're really easy
to write in a small small number of
lines of code in this framework
so probably like one thing you might be
wondering it looks like it's really easy
to write these complicated features but
like how do you actually run this thing
right like somewhere you have to kind of
like go connect to all of your data
stores or your production systems so
basically what we do here is like we
have sort of like an a syntax tree from
what our users have written and then we
can kind of like almost write compilers
for for any given back-end we want to
run it on to be able to like evaluate
that so we can do this in different
contexts like we can do it if we want to
create the training set by looking
across the total history and kind of
like computing the features at every
single point in time where we can do it
at the current time given the event
sources so we have a few different
backends like an interpreter a MapReduce
like back-end that we use you know you
can run the with like scolding or SPARC
to produce your training data and then
we also have a push based real-time
back-end
where you know you sort of like take a
single event and like do kind of a
scatter gather across all of these
different operations and lookups and
like you know go write something to a
store here and look it up there and then
like write out the result so all of
these the important thing is that our
machine learning engineers don't have to
think about any of them they just write
in their future code it's really simple
and then if you learning infrastructure
team gets to do the fun part of like
figuring out how to actually run all
these things but one of the nice things
here is that because this is all hidden
from the user
like you know if stripe decides to
migrate any of our technologies here or
if we're just like interested in trying
something else out our users don't even
have to know about it
our internal users here it's like
something that we can do as a systems
team and it's like totally opaque to
them so it gives us a lot of flexibility
to do things like performance
optimizations or just to like be working
with different technologies or whatever
the different means are for like where
we need to be running and evaluating our
features so this code is not not going
talk through this but basically the
point is that we do actually do this and
it does actually run this is some an
example from our MapReduce like back end
that we kind of like compile this
intermediate representation that we can
run in batch jobs we have kind of one of
these for each context that we want to
run and whether it's batch job or
whether it's this push based real-time
system so then you might wonder you know
do you actually use this in production
yes we absolutely use this in production
it's being used in our new launch of the
radar product to generate really a
pretty amazing set of pretty complicated
and highly predictive features so and
you know I mentioned that it's sort of
easy like our users have sort of
surprised us with their creativity they
have written some pretty amazing sets of
features the most complicated kind of
feature graphs that we seen have around
1,400 feature and event nodes and kind
of on the real-time side in our push
based system we're able to update
features for pretty complex future
graphs in around p99 of 60 milliseconds
which on the one hand is not like super
fast like this is you know a fair amount
slower than a lot of our model
evaluation but these are pretty large
graphs and this can involve like writing
to writing a reading from a bunch of
different stores and updating a lot of
keys so I think when you think about it
in that context it actually is pretty
performant and something like 60
milliseconds like you know if you're
thinking about trying to prevent fraud
in a transaction like it takes you like
a couple of seconds actually usually to
make an online transaction you have to
do things like reach out to banks those
things take a little bit of time so kind
of in that context I think 60
milliseconds is like not a bad price to
pay in order to like have really
predictive features that stop fraud from
going through to your business
and then in terms of how this all fits
together it's a little bit complicated
this is this is actually not the
transaction fraud case per radar it's a
slightly different application but
basically we kind of start with what we
call physical events which are things
that pop out of Kafka cues we turned
them into more like kind of like logical
events through this futures framework we
and then through whatever compiler we're
running whether it's the push based
real-time system or the batch system we
create some kind of like future job and
then we pass that to our model scoring
system which we call diorama
because dioramas are for models and we
love puns and then here you can see also
the sort of like push based real-time
system that we call pedlar which writes
out to these different stores in this
kind of a lambda system and you know
also write some events that we archive
so that's kind of what it looks like for
the real-time system and how we run it
and you know when we tell people about
some of the features that we've been
writing like a common question we get is
like oh are you going to open the source
of this and I think the answer is maybe
like you know it's hard to figure out
like which pieces here do you pull out
because I think one of the things that's
interesting about machine learning
infrastructure is that it's almost like
by definition built on top of all of
your company's other infrastructure and
so it's like a little bit less shareable
than some libraries that are really
great for open source but we're thinking
about it let us know if you're
interested so just to kind of like come
back a little bit and summarize what
I've talked about I told you about
system that gives a like sort of
restricted but very powerful API for
future engineers where you can construct
really complex features joining together
over a bunch of different types of
events but you don't have to think at
all about like how those features are
going to run from an implementation
point of view and you also don't have to
think about this like element of time
you can kind of prevent mistakes in time
agrarians and prevent mistakes with
label leakage that can lead to like
really really bad outcomes and your
modeling performance the sort of nature
of having these different back-end
systems means that as an infrastructure
team we have a lot of ability to
optimize or run in different
environments like it's easy to change
sort of how we compute without changing
like the logical meaning of the future
or sort of like what you're competing
and we basically been able to completely
separate the problem of like writing
business logic from implementation
details and that's let our machine
learning engineers just like you know
they had some before we started this I
think they had some backlog of maybe
like hundreds of features that they
wanted to try implementing and it was
like this painful process where every
every week or every month like maybe you
got through one of them maybe you put it
in production maybe there aren't any
bugs and they just kind of like cleared
all of them out it actually surprised us
a little bit and so you know finally
sort of freezer for the future engineer
from having to worry about temporal
consistency and then some of some of
these features that sound really
complicated like actually get pretty
easy to write which is really cool and
then like everyone else stripe is hiring
we have a lot of interesting roles for
data machine learning actually hiring an
engineering manager for our machine
learning infrastructure team so you
could be the person managing this really
cool work we as I mentioned you know we
use all the data technology a lot of our
applications are around tracking and
moving money so you know it's very high
stakes you know it's important to the
company you know it's important to your
users that's pretty cool to work on and
hopefully I've given you a little bit of
a picture of some of the
state-of-the-art infrastructure we've
built for future engineering we've also
done a lot of work that I haven't talked
about but we'd be happy to answer any
questions about for like model training
and both offline evaluation and the
online evaluation so thanks for
listening happy to answer any questions
and extra thank yous to the for folks
here you basically did all the technical
work that I talked about which I took
credit for as a manager so alright we've
got some time for questions if you've
got a question please just raise your
hand Ellie thanks for the talk I was
kind of curious whether you could speak
to feature reuse between machine
learning engineers yes that is an
awesome question so the question is sort
of like you know you have these
different applications like can you
reuse features between them and that was
actually I guess I didn't talk about it
but that was like a goal that we kind of
wanted to come to as well to make it
really easy to have this features
catalog basically and we've actually
already even in kind of like the first
few users people have like been able to
sort of wholesale we use large sets of
features and spin up new applications
really quickly the one thing you have to
be careful about is the versioning for
that because you don't want one person
to break another so all of these things
are feature sets are versioned and then
we have some kind of tooling like
previous versions that makes it harder
to like inadvertently clobber something
running in production or clobber
somebody else's thing yeah that's yeah
this is just in code in like one repo
but you know people organize their
finals pretty well so they're like you
know here's the file for like the card
counters or like here's the file for the
behavioral features so it's pretty easy
for flow to tell what's what's in it and
be able to use
for our people is technically wrong
whatever season yes yeah so whether or
whether we persist the result is a great
question it probably depends a little
bit in which context we're running them
in so like in real time like basically
any time we score any model we need
definitely blog where all the features
are in addition to kind of updating the
scores stores on the batch side like
sort of the batch process produces some
help but I think kind of what you're
guiding at may be is about having to
recompute a lot so one of the things
that was another kind of important idea
that we wanted going in was to design
features these kind of complex sets of
features so that you can still break
them apart like internally and that
should enable us to do some kind of like
smart feature fashion where we can store
things like you know maybe over some
some time bucket and then like if
nothing's changed and the future hasn't
changed then you don't have to recompute
it and that's actually pretty important
like you know if you're if you're
trading something like fraud models you
generally want to run it over some
decent amount of time like the scale
transactions is not web scale and just
like the time periods is issued when
things are a little bit longer like it
takes you some time to get the label was
this disputed or if you're writing a
model for credit risk like sort of the
span over which credit risky things
happen it's just like a little bit
longer so people actually are like being
able to be compute overall of streams
data so I think that like being set up
to eventually be able to kind of have
better caching of features will be
really really useful for the development
cycle
um as far as a fraud detection that you
guys do is there a lot of overlap
between what if you guys do and what
your credit-card companies do or yeah
that's a good question so their credit
card companies definitely do you know
some of their own evaluation and if
you've ever like traveled to another
state and trying to buy gas and then
like not has the transaction go through
[Music]
they don't tell us what their models are
although they do give us like you know
we work with them and they give us
things like files about whether the
charges disputed there's suddenly a lot
of things that they this and that we
want to be able to provide for our users
and like in some cases we have more
information than they do right like you
know we have all the information we can
capture from the payment page like some
things like potentially behavioral
features or like GIP features and they
just like have no way of knowing that so
that's kind of why it's really important
that users have good integrations with
us so that we get as much information as
possible and then we can kind of we also
know like what's going on over the
entire stream network right so the more
users we have the better our moles are
as we can see that you know your card
was just used like on this other
business from a totally different
location so I think basically like
everyone kind of runs their own models
but they have they have different
information sort of related to that you
know we've also kind of tried to model
like what are the card networks models
which is like a declines model rather
than a fraud model but that's pretty
interesting problem too
anywhere also the president so the super
cool Rebecca as I can imagine it one
losers maybe uh computer anyway how
often you sample that points in time
what the world looks like then that
gives you those yeah so a necessary
question and I guess we're not actively
sampling time that Martian it like what
events do we get but you know we have
for example events for every charge so
like our biggest users will have four
events grade so then we still have this
problem of like your training stuff has
like a whole lot of your top user so
we've done a bunch of different things
like we tried kind of different least
filter we also now for a lot of our
larger users we actually develop like
user specific models for them that are
only traded on their data and then we
can kind of compare that against the
global model and see like is the
performance better for them and it is
well give them like their own special
model so I think that's definitely
something to look at in terms of like
what data goes into the model training
but also like how we break apart like so
we don't just have one model but
actually like you know hundreds model
[Music]